[Music]
Fernando I think you are doing something
that has been a real passionate part of
my life and that is that you're
combining science and art and I think it
was a mistake in our culture to ever
separate the two there's a lot of
Mythology around that people often talk
about for example right brain versus
left brain and a lot of people don't
realize that there's really no
scientific evidence of that at all it's
more of an analogy than anything else
there isn't one part of your brain
that's logical and scientific and
another that's creative and artistic and
I find that there's as much reality and
and profound exploration of the universe
that can be done through art as is done
through science I think there are
different ways of humans exploring and
pushing the boundaries of what we know
and what we can do and one of the things
that I've been very proud in my life is
collaborating with artists trying to
actually add science into their art and
at NASA we actually have many many
artists that work for us some of them do
things that you your are fairly routine
in the sense that we have lots of data
coming in from the Hubble Space
Telescope and the artists may help us
get the images looking beautiful help us
frame them right we may have data coming
in from earth science satellites just in
the form of numbers and artists help us
make that into beautiful maps and
simulations that help us understand the
atmosphere but it might surprise you to
know that we actually have conceptual
artists at NASA - artists that aren't
tasked with dealing with imagery or data
but they're asked simply to interpret
discoveries through their art and one of
the most amazing people at NASA is a man
named Dan Goods at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and you can find him on the
internet and he's done TED talks on this
as well and Dan simply is a conceptual
artist trying to make people understand
viscerally how profound some of the
discoveries we make are he's done art
installations about planets around other
stars there's one that gets me every
time it's very simple you walk into the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory and there's a
floor-to-ceiling series of just clear
plastic columns and they have little LED
lights inside them and
dan has linked this in real-time to when
we are uploading instructions to our
spacecraft in space and when we are
downloading the data and you actually
see that as lights little lights and the
LEDs and the columns moving up towards
space in a beautiful pattern and then
when we're downloading data say from a
spacecraft around Jupiter when we're
receiving it you see the lights coming
down as new information comes down from
space and as you walk around during your
day at JPL you see the pulse of
discovery right in front of you and it's
real it's actually linked to the
commands coming to and from the
spacecraft so it makes you pause and
think about what you're doing and and
this is to me the real core of art to
make you stop question the reality
around you think about what's really
going on how you could view it
differently so many organizations take
this very seriously there are workshops
there are conferences on the
intersection of art and science there's
even a new acronym you may have heard of
the acronym stem in education which
stands for science technology
engineering and mathematics and a lot of
people across the discipline and across
the world are trying to change that to
steam science technology engineering
arts and mathematics they're not
separate they should be presented as a
whole people learn science differently
people's minds work differently art can
help people learn science so there is
really this wonderful synergy that can
exist between art and science so there
isn't a single institution I can point
you to in terms of you know these people
specialize in that but know that there
really is a very serious inclusion of
art in the science that's going on right
now and that needs to continue I think
even for the survival of science we have
to make something relevant to our
culture and relevant to people and an
art is going to help us do that
[Music]